[Music]
arguably it's just easier to be a man
and so therefore you're like well it's
easier
why is it easier to be a man one man i
mean the gender pay gap just says it all
out okay but there's also a gap in like
men commit suicide more yeah men are
dropping out of colleges but that's
toxic masculinity that men can't speak
about so then so then why why are we
saying that there's like a patriarchy
when men have at heart too like why are
you just saying you said you you just
said women have it harder than men but
if women had it harder than men like
then why aren't i i didn't say they had
it harder i just thought it was easy to
be a guy then but okay if it's easier to
be a guy then why do more men commit
suicide because they they feel because
of toxic masculinity which are
perpetrated by both men and women they
feel like they have to be macho and i
don't subscribe to that at all i'm very
much like
could it be possible that men have a
harder life than women yeah of course it
could be possible of course it could be
okay so that would like contradict what
you said earlier well this is it it's
not black and white it's not right or
wrong yeah gray area maybe yeah so
everything is there's no like very solid
so yeah that's and
even the whole um
rule and exception there's all it's not
one size fits all it's really not where
there is there are some men who
thrive and succeed because they're a man
because life is easy therefore i'd be
like i would expect you okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you an example my dad's
the half top half a percentage of
earners okay he he's the white man right
that but but here's the thing he worked
80 hours a week my whole life i didn't i
didn't get to see him yeah how how is
that like the patriarchy when my dad put
in 80 hours every week his whole life
from the time i was like a child right
missed a lot a lot of a lot of [ __ ] like
he earned that yeah and i'm never going
to say that's like no the patriarchy
well anyway but now now he's a white
male ceo yeah right so is is that the
patriarchy or did women not choose to do
that well that's the only way we could
argue is the only definitive answer you
could have is if you had a exact female
replica to be like she likely would not
get where he is that's the only way we
could argue it right so it doesn't want
to take away from his efforts it doesn't
take away from him so then why do we why
do we talk about it at all if you can't
if you have no idea why there's a pay
gap
yeah yeah yeah like like it's is it
possible that it's the the industries
that women pick because if you if you
look at countries that have more choice
so if you go to like the most
egalitarian countries there's more of a
pay gap rather than less because women
choose jobs with people
and yeah
jobs with objects so like my i'm from a
family of ten
all the boys are engineers none of the
girls are engineers like is it possible
it's a biological difference rather than
a patriarchy yeah no i think i think
well i think the pay gap is more like
within so i don't know if you saw on
international women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being
a financer
yes but the pay gap then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like i will not
uh sign on to this contract unless i
know my female counterparts are being
paid the same and so i think the pay gap
then comes and well it's also the truth
it's also the trait like
disagreeableness so as women like we're
naturally more agreeable 100 so so we're
i'm more i'm terrible at negotiating i
just want to make everyone happy and i
just want to be like yeah i'll do
whatever for nothing and
um and but that's like men are more
disagreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences yeah no
and gender they are so real so in my
studies um it showed that so
men are more likely to go for so let's
say there's a job and a woman is more
likely to look at a job specification
and go
oh but she's more likely to say no to
herself and she's more likely to go
um
oh i don't know if i'm good enough yeah
whereas a man is more likely to actually
inflate their ability and be like i'm
gonna go for that and it actually
reflects in relationships where a man is
more likely to actually
shoot above and be like yeah yeah i can
i can yes
so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like like i spent a lot of my life being
like i'm a four out of ten i'm
i'm probably about seven but i spent a
lot of my life dating men and people
would be like amy that guy is not in
your league like why do you not and
they're like they're definitely like you
know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
well
right there that's because men and women
men and women value different things
men value looks more women don't value
looks as much they they value things
like social status like a blue check
mark
a blue and this is yeah i've dated a guy
with a blue check mark right like we'd
like social status yeah like we'd be
lying if we said we didn't care no or or
whatever it is like it's it could be
height right it could be like it could
be you know maybe he's not as good
looking facially but he's he makes money
yeah or he makes money yeah right and so
that's why we see there's a gap in that
yeah yeah we don't we don't scream
patriarchy for like men yeah yeah like
but then we don't know that's it we
don't know is it because of
uh so you've got the biopsychosocial
approach um and that which is what i
tend to um subscribe to because that's
it it's not easy to be like oh it's just
biology or it's just sociology or it's
just your personal my question is like
yeah i just don't even understand like
in this day and age how we are fighting
the patriarchy like what more can they
do i can do any job i want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like i don't even
know like i don't even know what i need
feminism for now like i can't think of
one thing um i have a
question going back to what you said and
i think it's bad but i want to
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men is
because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy
you should expect more from them
or they have advantages
right more so than women right
so
my question then
is
would you
apply a higher standard to a white woman
over for example a black male
yeah you would yeah i would i would
really
so you would expect the white woman to
earn a certain amount
to be taller than you
to make you feel protected and to be
able to provide for you more so than if
you were getting to know a black male
all right well
then it's the intersection between race
and gender but that's it as a
westernized white woman i'm well aware
of my privilege
um and it's like i know that
like ah it depends on well that's it it
depends on
oh it's tough it's because i'll be i'll
be honest like i think women just always
apply a higher standard to men than
women because it meant regardless what
race they are so say like we go for a
job interview and oh wait wait you're
non-binary me and him
yeah who are you dating
[Applause]
like who you
who are you picking yeah he probably
makes more money than me yeah but then
but then but then being a female i'd
probably be like is money my most
important or is it emotional connection
and how funny you are like it would
depend on what as a woman i think i
would oh i don't know
that's it would would i well as a woman
that doesn't necessarily want kids any
time soon and is quite financially
independent i probably wouldn't be like
money probably wouldn't be my priority
so then i'd be like what physical
attractive would come into it but then
funny okay so it's really good
but it's really hard it's really hard
no but it's really hard to be like
is it just money is it protection
because i'm also quite scrappy so i can
hold my own as well i don't want a man
to protect me because i'll fight do you
do you think you could fight me
yeah
do you think you could beat me in a
fight yeah because i'll just go straight
through the eyes straight over the eyes
and you are disabled yeah i will i will
let you believe that that's it that's if
you're trying to fight me and i blind
you in one eye you're not gonna
you're not gonna fight i'm like not even
okay you can blind him in one eye and
he'll knock you out like i don't think
if someone's blinding you in an audience
i i think that's a very nice i'm not
allowed to hit women so yeah this is a
very nice that's a double standard hit a
woman i'm i'm gonna hit me thank you i
think if a girl hits a man he can knock
her out he can knock her out yeah you
can yeah i would only
fellas don't do it it's not worth it you
know you're gonna get double the jail
time it's not worth it but then again
that's a double standard because then
other men will start to hit you and be
like you hit a woman no no if she
started on you you've got every right
every right i would say if my life is
threatened then fine but if if my life
isn't threatened i'll grapple her but i
won't i won't punch her in the throat i
think the majority of girls will hit a
guy if push comes to shelf because they
believe that one they're protected and
two they're not gonna oh did you did you
know statistically in terms of the the
line of crossing over to physical abuse
women crossed that line more
statistically speaking i don't know i
would believe that but it's actually but
all it is is that when men cross the
line
men are when naturally more aggressive
and violent so when men cross the line
there are there are harsher consequences
right for the woman physically but like
and i mean like i mean just like a woman
if she gets annoyed she goes oh for
[ __ ] sake like yeah do you know what i
mean like women actually cross that line
more than men do
yeah i can get like i like to punch
people in the arm i like to just be like
i don't know why but i'll just but
that's technically abuse that's
separately i've technically just abused
you but if a man punched me and
especially if you're in public people
like what the [ __ ] you just punched it
i'll be like
but no i'm a
i think
again it's responsibility that if i hit
someone man woman young old black white
i'm like i'm fully ready for you to hit
me back at least the equality i
respected i'm fully ready for you
i will not hit someone if i'm not
prepared for them to hit me back okay i
will not yeah okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
read some super chat so
4.99 for mr ride do okay equality and
female liberation because
is because white men allowed it
do you include that in um you know in
non-white countries that's my question
is feminism rampant in non-white
countries i don't know how i like
feminism
in nigeria i couldn't tell you is it i
don't know okay i was like i think you
said i know oh i don't i don't know oh
yeah because i can't think of a white
country or a black like a country that's
not maybe japan i could see japan maybe
but then but then you also would argue
then as a black male
like are you for feminism or supportive
or like open to like yeah uh if you ask
my opinion i i honestly believe that
current day feminism
i'm not for it mainly because i believe
it destroys the black community
personally
okay fair enough yeah i think it i think
it massively has
destroyed the black nuclear family in
the western world which is why
it's interesting because black
immigrants do significantly better than
the black locals in any western country
and a big part of that is because they
have a nuclear family when they come
over
i
yeah i i can't really comment i don't
know enough about it to comment on it
yeah
okay